what would you say um would be unlike
one of the number one investments to
make
oh you mean not cars right right like
you just said cars is not really a good
investment to make so what would be like
a number one investment to me okay so
the number one investment you can
possibly make is in yourself amen 100
whether that's education whether that's
uh
mental we'll talk about mental whether
that's emotional whether that's getting
bigger faster stronger sexy or cool or
smarter anything
improving yourself reading books taking
classes get taken courses watching
valuetainment all that kind of good that
is the by far and away the number one
investment you can possibly make number
two
okay then you start talking about
appreciating assets there's appreciating
assets and depreciating assets
depreciating assets being
you know what i always say cars close
jewelry cars close jewelry depreciate
ads those are the big three of
depreciating assets cars go down in
value your clothes go down in value your
jewelry typically is down to value
appreciating assets now you're talking
real estate you're talking the stock
market you're even talking certain
crypto right now you're talking i'm i
don't i don't own property but i own
reits are you familiar with reits real
estate investment trust so it's rather
than owning one place i own a portfolio
of houses right now so it's
understanding the difference of
appreciating assets and depreciating
assets but the number one investment you
can possibly make is it improving
yourself awesome thank you for that and
one more question on this topic before
we go on to the next one why do you
think so many people in
society in our culture now invest in
things like money clothes shoes
invest say that again invest invest in
things such as jewelry yeah
well a lot of it is um
materialistic consumerism i i'm trying
to keep up with the joneses it's it's
all that there's something called
lifestyle creep you were making 50 grand
a year you were just kind of getting by
you got a bonus hey oh you got a 20
grand bonus now i'm making 70 grand i
got to start living like i'm making 70.
what i did is i was making no money like
i was literally like the most i ever
made before i got into financial
services was 25 grand okay
and then boom i made 100 grand so that
75 grand difference i just put it in the
bank and just kept living like a broke
dude and then i started making 200 grand
and 400 grand and 500 grand and
obviously i started you know living in a
little bit nicer places and i don't have
a car but i started making making making
money but i was like i do i don't need
the lavish things in life to tell me who
i am that was me some people need it
some people need to have that cool car
because they they want to look cool for
girls some people need to get the 20 000
watch because they want to you know they
want to flash you know millennials you
know you know the stats these days
are 40 of americans making a hundred
grand or more are living paycheck to
paycheck
sixty percent of millennials
making a hundred grand or more are
living paycheck to paycheck so it's not
a freaking i'm a poor thing it's not
that you don't have any money it's
you're broke and you're living paycheck
to paycheck because you're spending all
your freaking money on things that to
maybe try to look cooler allowed to look
better keep up with the joneses it's
called lifestyle creep the more you make
the more you feel like you need to spend
so that's i think the biggest problem
right now i love that thank you for
sharing that and to bring it full circle
with what you just stated because you're
basically spending all this money on
material things to validate yourself
which goes back to the number one thing
to say if they were investing in
themselves they wouldn't need that
validation to feel like they're
successful
you